Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates the sponsors of this segment  shares the laws regarding pedestrians  and their right of ways here is today's  legal minute  I'm attorney Eric Palacios welcome to  the legal minute today's question is  when do pedestrians have the right of  way  if you see a pedestrian in a crosswalk  you have to yield the right-of-way to  that person pedestrians must cross with  the signal or light if there is one if a  pedestrian is crossing where there is no  crosswalk or not at an intersection The  Pedestrian must then yield to traffic  it's important to note that just because  you have the right-of-way doesn't mean  that you can run over a pedestrian you  can have the right-of-way and still be  liable for hitting someone if you could  have avoided the Collision if you have  any legal questions please call us at  702-444-7777  give Eric Palacios and Associates a call  or visit their website at Eric  palacioslaw.com in Las Vegas